you know those cool travel photos though
when when they do a bird's-eye view and
it's all like straight Nolan well then
I'm a NOLA NOLA is essential hi I'm dr.
Montgomery and these are my essentials
[Music]
may I please have my first essential I
feel like a total dick
I'm happy to get out I'm happy to get up
and do it thanks buddy
these are my blue good pair they're so
dirty I can hardly see it's just a haze
and then these ones they're kind of cool
if you're wearing navy beige and then
these are like polarized but they have a
little bit of a blue tint and I love the
gold frame my girlfriend she actually
gave me these I literally will not spend
money on sunglasses I just sit on them I
lose them I've lost so many pairs of
Sunny's I usually keep him in a case but
on this instance they're just thrown in
because we had a late flight like this
is really the essentials that I think
that you need a good comb I used a fine
end on the sides because my hair's
thicker on the sides so it gets it a bit
more streamline you know what I mean and
then you use the lighter ones on top so
you can get those nice parts through
your
these are really important eyedrops just
keep your eyes hydrated after our late
flight I had to put a whole bucket of
these in my Isis woman to wake up I dare
give away this secret
this is the best cologne you will ever
smell in your life it's Tom Ford Black
Orchid smells so like woody and sweet
it's kind of masculine and feminine at
the same time it's the best unisex scent
I've even got a little travel version
and then Aesop do really good like
unisex it just smells so like woody this
one's far more kind of earthy I think
then that one that one's quite floral
it's very hard to find something that
you can match that the oils of your skin
don't kind of push you out and it
rejects and this is one of the few ones
I find for me hang so I can spread it on
a jacket like a jacket that I'll never
wash and it smells like that you know
what I mean I could tell you smelling
good is essential I was given these as a
gift a while ago these are like the
original ones and then I bought these
ones which are like water proofs for
kind of versions they're noise
cancelling they look like that little
green light and then you just pop them
in and they go do and then they say
connected I already can't hear myself
reading they're so good we go surfing in
Sydney and these surfers where our these
earbuds like off off the coast out in
the water and they have like these
earbuds in and they have Apple watches
on and I'm like oh these guys listening
to music like I can't think of anything
better I'm also not skilled enough of a
surfer to go surfing and not lose them
yet whereas these guys don't even get
their hair wet I don't even know how
they do it
this is really good because I travel a
lot so I need to be able to when I'm
landing pop it in and pop open the sim
holder and basically put in you know
whatever country I mean whatever seemed
that that country equates to
surprisingly essential my friends
actually yeah soon this will not be a
central then redundant so when I started
traveling a few years ago my sister who
is 12 years younger than me gave me two
of these and one was to keep her beside
her bed while I'm away traveling and one
was for me to take and I think it's hard
to understand especially as a younger
human why your brother is away so I
think this is just a nice little token
she actually only started wanting to
watch stranger things recently and she's
enjoying the show now when I was in
drama school we had to do this animal
week where we had to be animals and I
did the most terrible impression of an
owl I don't know why I was giving her
now so there's probably a joke lying
somewhere in this may it's not gonna
happen way too embarrassed I have like
so many different gaps I'm not a
baseball fan so this is totally not
representative of me I just love the
beige I'm all about the beige I wear
mostly like the cheese cutter capstan on
I mean like the old New York newspaper
boy style with clips on the side and
they're called like cheese cutter hats
because you need to leave they used to
put the knife down the side and do the
belt up over it I don't know why you'd
put a knife that close to your head but
that was what I heard
so I usually wear those I would say a
hat is essential so this is my passport
hold up
my mom is Canadian my dad's a Kiwi and I
was born in Australia so I keep my hefty
collection in here
um it just depends I feel like Australia
Canada and New Zealand you can pretty
much go anywhere on the planet and be
welcomed with a smiling face I have the
same necklace that I I wear everywhere I
actually ended up getting it into
strange things
Billy wears it as well it's like a Saint
Christopher kind of necklace and my
girlfriend got me I don't know you guys
know David Yurman they do the most
amazing pieces marry this shipwreck
collection it's like beautiful Aztec
type jewellery a lot of his stuff has
horses this is a horse I really like all
the horse imagery on jewelry and kind of
like it in tribute to like mafiosos the
horse racing sort of stuff that you
still going on and stuff like this
Sopranos and we were shooting stranger
things we watched the whole take all the
seasons in Atlanta I heard they're
remaking out [ __ ]
and this is some things you shouldn't
touch that's not essential not essential